un economista de formación británica
mwai kibaki deja un legado de
crecimiento económico con sus grandes
proyectos de infraestructura e introdujo
la educación básica gratuita para los
niños
y bach pero su paso por el poder también
se vio empañado por escándalos de
corrupción y gastos suntuosos y su
disputada reelección en 2007 desencadenó
sangrientas batallas étnicas algo que no
se había visto en el país ni antes ni
después más de 1200 personas fueron
asesinadas y medio millón se vieron
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares el
viernes el presidente keniata presentó
sus respectos a su antiguo rival
político y declaró un período de luto
presidente kibaki walk forever
remember the gentleman
el presidente kibaki será recordado para
siempre como el caballero de la política
keniana un brillante orador cuya
elocuencia e ingenio y encanto ganaron
la partida una y otra vez the
time and time el twitter se ha inundado
de homenajes mayoritariamente positivos
algunos sin embargo fueron críticos como
el controversial político keniano de la
oposición ninguna ninguna que acusó a
kibaki de haber robado las elecciones de
2007 que iba aquí también será recordado
por la constitución de 2010 con la que
introdujo un sistema político más
descentralizado y limitó los poderes
presidenciales